what the hell stake time like that never
happens oh no why we've never done one
during the day but your there's no you
are a very busy man yeah I guess that's
true but we got done shooting early
today so it's like a come over yeah so
here we go and one episode to start with
uh this is hug wolf and it is again
seems like a real return to the very
bizarre and just sort of nonsensical
like early episodes which is fine it was
fun um and the only thing that okay so
you got this server where hug wolf that
they come across well they're trying to
burn down this tree that's just like a
bad tree or something and it doesn't
look like it's doing anything it's just
that and that this hug wolf comes out
and hiss at Finn puts it hugging me
gently and it seems to be yet that hug
wolf runs away but then he turns into a
hug wolf - and he just hugs people and
he hugged the whole town and everyone's
really angry and it looks good Oh baby
he feels terrible and they lock him up
but he escapes he finds the other hug
wolf and they give it you're such a big
hug but biggest hunk of all time that
they eventually stopped and this
explosion of hug happens in this big
heart and there was this girl there who
is like I just wanted to stop hugging
he's like yeah me too
and then Jake's like can I get a hug and
she turns into what looks like the tree
thing Jake screams and it just stops I
have no idea what that ending was about
again it just reminds me a lot of like
the early the early episodes cuz a lot
of those endings I just feel like what
the hell yeah so um I have no idea where
we're gonna figure out what that was or
not but uh it was fun it was fine I'll
say this I usually and what this guy
remind me of him like the did you ever
watch Ren Stimpy yeah of course the
later episodes whoa okay I washed up
until
like I never watched the adult party one
no no what I hate it I couldn't stand
that I'm talking about like just the end
season like the one for kids like the
fight like maybe the final season or
something like that
I don't know that she got to the final
season but I may have it's sort of what
I think they took it out of the hands of
the creator for one but I don't know but
they they went this direction where it's
just sort of like everything's opposite
which is like you know they're trying to
do a dirt farm but then vegetables grow
and they're like oh no we have to were
ruined we have to leave the farm and
like it that's kind of funny but they
take it so seriously and they just drag
on the drama for it that like I don't it
didn't work for me near the end and I'm
saying to myself I should be doing the
same with this one cuz it's kind of one
joke that everyone doesn't like hugs and
they show there's nothing wrong with
hugs you know and even that little baby
it's like mommy our looks good and she's
like oh baby yeah but it'll baby laughs
and I don't know why maybe there is
something just to the speed and the
energy and the strangeness well again 11
minutes compared to we'll say 24 minutes
you know I think if we do an episode
about hugging for another you know 10
minutes yeah we yeah I think that's kind
of maybe what it is oh no I never saw
that episode it's I mean I just remember
around to the point where it's like and
that's a it's a good point if those were
like 11 that or a shorter you know it's
like those would be funny but yeah this
was like whatever 24 yeah it's like that
back Kasich's uh but I thought was well
I like the I like the fact they have
hearts you know like this generic hearts
for the hands and the feet um this is
another but um and I thought it was fine
you know there's one bit I was like
aside from the ending where I was like
what was that and I was sitting you saw
a bubblegum chosing a cat does that ever
come into play in anything or is it just
like some sort of way okay so we don't
know uh how about you what you think of
it I'm sure you'd bring up the daughter
and the the dad get out of here you
forgive you American teacher bang bang
he's shouting the guns yeah and then
after like the thing leader after the
hug well he's like she's never gonna
marry bag and he's making his own sound
effects I just after I seen I said
what's their story it was so odd or her
waking up Dracula so yeah I don't know
what their story is uh I guess I'm
intrigued but not enough to bring it up
in a V long cuz apparently I forgot
about it um no I it's it's a fine
episode it's cute it's got its bonuses
I'm a horror fan so I need take on the
you know now generic werewolf
like storyline makes me giggle every
time what am I looking system well and
werewolves like you know out of the
classic monsters like whatever vampires
and mummies and stuff like that like
werewolves are the ones I think of a
coolest like I just freaking love
werewolves I don't know why it is it's
just something like I don't like I don't
think they're especially scary they're
just cool just something about three
into a giant wolf is really awesome so
yeah so anything that has like a where
or something or blank wolf whatever I'm
just sorta like cool like let's go so it
could be that - I don't know so I love
BMO
you know you know it's just incredibly
cute then again be most always cute so
there's something else I'm wondering
about
I just noticed about BMO is he got the B
- got the M and then you have his arm
like coming out of the oh I'm just
realizing like was it always just be em
and they were just reading the oh like
me maybe what he was originally named
after was a choice IBM and then they
just thought the arm was the Oh or
something but it's really just part of
the arm the interesting interesting
theory you'll actually find out oh do
you you do actually find out okay I know
that's that'd be cool I know it's in
this one because his arm was he sheets
arm was a little Jimmy got to be in the
M but then the arm was like a little
over eight didn't match up exactly with
me and so I was thinking like oh hey
maybe it's maybe it was BM something the
whole time so just call beemo beemo
female mr. beam oh yeah but where's it
it's it yeah it's just call it to BMO I
BMO's to BMO BMO's to BMO yes it's not
fine with that yeah any closing thoughts
no I think George should be in the next
one though she'll like the next one
you'll like the next one yeah
not me though would you do it if we hug
always one hug no he was talking about
hugging me stay away from this woman
whoa wait a minute